I've got a double date ladies.
It's my co-pilot, Ross Mathews.
Hi.
(audience cheers and claps)
Because I just figured, you know, listen,
I love being a third wheel
but when a girl is lucky enough to have a date
like Rossi, well, I want to hang with my Rossi.
That's right, I'm a dreamboat.
Can't help it.
You certainly are.
Anyway, I wanted to play a fun game with you guys
that we're calling ready,
"If you did the crime, you must sip the wine"
(audience cheers and applauds)
Okay, I'm gonna read some questions
and if you've done the crime,
then you must take a sip of your delicious, fresh vine wine.
Ready?
Yes, we're ready.
All right.
And we can all participate in each question.
Okay, everyone.
First, take a sip if you've ever lied to a best friend.
Well, actually if it's a surprise birthday party
that you're planning, you have to lie to your best friend.
Oh, that's true.
I had a friend cut bangs once
and I told her it was cute and they weren't.
(guests laughs)
Okay, that makes sense.
Okay, take a sip if you've ever re gifted something.
Are you getting me drunk?
Take a sip.
This is good, by the way.
This is so amazing.
So good
Take a sip if you've ever sent a racy text
to the wrong person.
The wrong person?
Way too many times.
Oh, Drew!
How do you get that wrong?
Okay, here's the irony though
is I'm not name dropping.
You two ladies are both in the same industry.
My best friend happens to be Cameron Diaz.
And I sent her a video of me getting dressed and I sent it,
it turns out to a 16 year old boy named Matthew.
Anyway, long story.
He then wrote me back and was like,
"I have your video, but I promise I won't like
put it out anywhere."
Oh my god.
Hi Matthew.
And I'm only getting dressed, not to be sexy
but I am like doing this to her,
but it's because I was trying to multitask
and she's my best friend.
And we get dressed in front of each other all the time.
So anyway.
Take a sip if you
I love that story.
You do?
You know, thank God for Matthew
being such a kind young gentleman
not to put it out there in the world.
Okay, take a sip if you've ever faked it.
Oh God (laughs)
What might you would be referring to?
You know, it.
(audience laughs)
Drew, I see you taking
I'm gonna drink some wine while I think about it.
(Ross laughs)
I'm gonna take another sip.
I did it once just to see what it was like.
I was like, I guess maybe this is just be a fun time
to try what that's all about.
Like boring.
Really?
Did you really sell it though?
I tried to.
I was like, I wonder, you know
I wanted to do my best "When Harry met Sally" impression.
I totally went for it.
(indistinct) by the way.
We all know how to fake it, but I was like
I want to see if it works and convinces this person.
I guess it's also a good way to just end it.
Yeah, let's wrap this up.
All right.
If you've ever, take a sip if you've ever,
I can't believe you're getting shy on this one.
I know, right?
Take a sip if you've ever cleaned out a toilet bowl
with an ex-boyfriend's toothbrush,
and then put it back for them to brush with.
Oh my gosh! (laughs)
I want to know who this ex boyfriend is.
While you were dating them or after you broke up?
While we were dating.
We weren't together and he deserved it.
Does he know?
I also sabotaged a cake I made him.
I let the dogs eat it before I served it
Okay.
I'm obsessed with you.
Am I the only person that's ever done anything like this?
The only person who's admitted it on TV.
(audience laughs)
Has anyone ever done anything like,
you know, to someone who might have wronged you,
you know in a relationship?
No.
Never, yeah, no.
Sorry Drew.
I also spray painted an ex boyfriend's car
in the middle of the night.
We put on like, you know, balaclavas
and blasted Cypress Hill
and then got out and spray painted like his precious car.
And he was like, "Someone sabotaged my car last night."
It wasn't you, was it?"
And I was like, "Uh-uh."
(guests laugh)
We're learning a lot about you.
Today, we can't do that because of Instagram,
and cameras and all sorts of things.
Too much evidence.
Dang it.
It's true.
This was all in the nineties.
Okay, let's take a sip
if you've ever been on the Drew Barrymore show
and had a great time.
(audience cheers and applauds)
We're gonna have a lot.
Yeah, cheers.
We love you guys so much
and be sure to get yourself a nice bottle
of fresh vine wine.
(upbeat music plays)